so let's give this a go now
there's there's two twists to this
problem okay um which is somewhat cool
because question five i think it's like
the first three unit question in the
paper being that it's a combined paper
anyway um the first twist is that you've
got different bases okay so you have to
do something with this in order to get
these two logs talking to each other
right different bases you can't do
anything with it just like with um
fractions if you've got different
denominators they can't talk to each
other if it's thirds if you've got
different things underneath the square
root can't talk to each other right so
what are we going to do
go change the bass the question is how
so how are we going to change the bass
okay so remember how does change of bass
generally work okay if you've got oh
that works how am i doing that that's
good
um if i take this okay and i want to
change its base all right the idea is
that this a will become the log on the
bottom of my fraction and the b will
become one on the top and you can pick a
new base you can pick whatever you like
okay so in your calculator you might be
log base 10
okay or if you're
lazy like me you don't write so much you
might pick um a natural log so that's
base e
okay but the point is that in this case
what base we after right well i'm going
to change
sorry
you can choose either it won't matter
eventually actually i think one is
better than the other
i think i think base two would be better
i think yeah
you'll you'll see why later
um
the idea is i'm going to choose base
base a no
b i want to change the base so this is
what i'll get
okay
so can you see what i've done going from
here to here i've chosen a new random
base it just happens to be one of these
other numbers and so this this part here
just becomes one
okay just happens to be all right now
how do i use that here um what did i
just say base two is better right so i'm
gonna leave this log base two
of x out the front i'm gonna change this
one
by changing the base and switching it
around it's going to become the
reciprocal that's this one over this
okay so i'm going to get 1 over
log base 2 of x okay now this is better
but it doesn't look much better right
because what can you do with that you
can monkey it around these things don't
mix very well what are you gonna do okay
and so this is the second challenge you
need to turn a log question
into a quadratic question okay so you
cannot avoid
multiplying through by log base 2 of x
okay so this is what i'm going to get
now a lot of you actually did this but
then you thought that that
squared term out the front i've got to
be able to do something with that and
you thought there must be some log law
that i'm forgetting um or use some other
log law in the wrong way like maybe you
put this two out the front which doesn't
work okay
um you actually the key is to actually
leave it like that okay this is a
quadratic equation
you've got log base two i know attorney
oops
of x squared minus
that
plus 1.
so do you remember when we were doing or
when you were doing last year equations
reducible to quadratics right so you
could write this as if you let u equal
log
base two of x okay this is just a
standard hole okay
uh
okay
does that match up yeah
okay yeah when can you move the two it's
probably a better question and the
answer is when you've got
the power inside the term uh it's called
the argument actually right so that you
can bring around to the front okay
but log 2x
multiplied by log base 2 of x
they don't they don't mix log terms
remember logs about time right so you
can add time and you can subtract time
and that works but multiplying time is
not anything meaningful okay so
the when the whole thing is squared like
here
you're just stuck okay
all right now
um you can do the substitution you don't
actually need to um you can launch
straight into quadratic formula because
you can see it doesn't factorize very
nicely uh and all you need to say is log
base 2 of x is equal to okay now
go for it you tell me what's right how
does quadratic formula start nine okay
so minus b
plus or minus the square root of
b squared minus
four
a c
okay yep
um all over
2a okay
so you've got 9 plus or minus the square
root of
77 and 2.
now log base 2 of x okay now what do i
do
what do i do from there
okay yeah so this is remember this is
two values but a log equation is just an
index equation in disguise right so i
just need to say
that this time or both of them really
i'll write here separately
minus or
okay
from this line i read off that x is
equal to
2 to the power of these things okay 2 to
the power of 9 minus root 77 on 2
and
oh sorry 2 to the power of 9 plus
intensity
which is gross
but that's the answer okay and that's
why i think they ask you to approximate
right yeah yeah uh two decimal places so
you can you can get your calculator and
that's what you're that's where you'll
get your values from yeah okay
do be cautious when you're popping this
in your calculator um watch out for your
brackets particularly when you go up in
the index and you've got square roots
and you're going to have at least two
sets of rackets on that to make sure you
get it right okay isn't it